has he had some good moments a couple of tough
moments in terms of penalties especially last
weekend but he's overcome those and Coach
bnar likes what he sees a up into it down
deep score Riley tuy right to the low slot at
the top of the crease he turns the blade over
for a perfect redirect and the ABS have taken an
early one- nothing lead execution was excellent
so tuy creates the turnover then there's a puck
battle goes right up to W now watch tuy just put
his stick right on the ice and say hey why put
it right here I'm going to deflect it right in
beautiful play nice upstairs and look at the old
chess pop he's feeling good that's his third goal
in exhibition crashing into the corner was Ben
barard blew an edge and went hard into the far
Corner olivon o coner back to olivon deflected
save by Wedgewood and he just got his left skate
on it the Carnage in front of the net but the
as had no Puck luck here come the Dallas Stars
Pino couldn't carry it in fired ahead L got
a baby break away it shoots and what a kick
save by wedw he flashed that right pad got
a toe on it turnover again Artu luckan going
period number one Artu linan trying to make
it two nothing but Wedgewood was there up to
Handley now B one timer by goria for stuffs it
in front lose p b that near but yeah Dallas been
on the afterburners here good for check good
Cycles Stu in the front of the net and right
there yeah because nothing ever just happens
easier overnight in you know NHL being a GM yeah
no that's that's that's a good point especially
when it's sort of internal contracts where there's
sort of you look forward to those sometimes
those hard deadlines to get things done with
which sort of is the July 1 type of time of year
or arbitration or or whatever but yeah there's
definitely some some tough nights that's for sure
been a competent defensive player good faceof guy
and and he has he has a lot of abilities put up
offense consistently in this league for a long
time so you know hearing him you know talk like
that is is a is a good thing but you got to get
it down the ice well there's Hanley coming in
providing a bit of a screen ni that was just a
quick little snapshot right there certainly
was kind of [__] a little bit by surprise
yeah yeah Hanley was cruising on the slot I think
that he thought that maybe that pass was going to
come across but you're right rer right low on the
ice if you're going to be in the American Hockey
League that's a that's a pretty good place to play
it's a beautiful part of Colorado it's sold out
it's a fun building and and it's a it's a really
important part of what you know what we do and and
and finding players and and putting them in a good
spot there's a good spot for deont Taves he lets
it go from way downtown that's Poston inan and the
ABS have taken a two to one lead Devon Tes that's
a power play goal yeah first penalty of the game
of course doesn't hurt when you have pretty much
the top line that's going to be there for the
regular season in exhibition on the power playe
T just rifles one in a great screen in front well
I like seeing drewan and leinen right there right
at the net that's uh that's what created the goal
in my opinion they're not the biggest guys in the
world Chris but but we talked about of course Ryan
Johansson I think he's tackled everything in his
career you know he's a he's a Workhorse and and
everything so far has been good so let's uh let's
let's hopefully that'll continue in front of the
avalan bench as steel was wrapped up by kir who's
got the puck down the slot save by Wedgewood
he robbed semy G who got that little backhand
flipper off thinking him is okay here's this young
young kid coming in now he's in year six coming up
year six 27 years old stolen by drwan down the
slap drwan a backand shot saved by Wedgewood to
Jonathan druin has been dangerous so far here this
evening Rock bore territory that one squirts right
through a mar now's trying to get numbers couldn't
quite do this P On's back defensively broken up
kick save and it's fo over the top of the net that
may be the best save of the night for Alexander
gioria the pile are preseason ranked number four
this season here's Jonathan drwan in 's it up for
McKinnon down the boards he goes in front looking
for Ron it's save by Redwood rebound it's tipped
away another save by Wedgewood as devont Taves
and worked his way gor with his blocker say just
get it out of here you know what I I'm on in the
mood to cover this one look it in with a centering
pass it's broken up Meers shoots save by Wedgwood
loose puck right down in front of him where is it
it's underneath the body Wedgewood was reaching
for it with his catching glove and finally we've
got a whistle and why it's nice to get used to
teammates line mates by some of the rookies it's
tough to get thrown in with brand new guys luck to
cross ice pass jot what a save by W rebound score
right out of midair Frederick olivon bats it home
after Westwood makes a terrific save it's a power
play goem with 20.8 to go a 3-1 lead and once
again Riley tuy what a pass by lein tuy doesn't
even hesitate just smashes it on net and then
right out of midair Frederick O Wilson pops it
there's the pass the slap shot he just picks that
out of midair Fredick Olson scores a beautiful
power play goal terrific job there as toughy just
fired at Wedgewood again Frederick olon the alone
goal scorer for Dallas is Nick kamano and so here
we are with the third per the Avalanche with two
PowerPlay goals and we do see a new goalie it's
always key that one the ABS lost lunk fist with
his shot blocked Away by shiman given off out
of The Far Side loose Puck comes through shot
save no a hit a mod who was down on the ice and
out of the box is Ben Meyers turnover watch out
shot save by gorv oh my goodness gracious Master
Donado had all kinds of time and ability and gorgi
have went way out pushed to the front of the cage
it's underneath gorgia it's a loose Puck it's kick
free and scored blue m cleans up right at the
top of the crease he's able to Ram it home in
a gold mouth scrum and the stars have made it a
three2 game with two 52 to go yor have had this
right underneath him and he had no idea where
it was watch right here he has no idea if he
just sits down he's going to be on that Puck and
then the Hungry Hippo as I like to call it begins
everybody just starts going after that puck it's
chaos in front and the Dallas Stars just swarm the
net until finally they get a little lucky keep
pucking in the back of the net she goes did you
like that game Hungry Hungry Hippos I thought it
was fantastic well you know what for the first
maybe two or three times you played it is yeah
and then of course you start to lose all the balls
Lindell tried to funnel it Far Side deflected TI
to the near side and steel takes over again final
30 seconds of the third period there's a one-time
score Niles lest rocks back and bangs it through
traffic the tie the game at three with 27.6
seconds left we have drama the execution here look
at that one touch pass and then across the slot
it's right in the absolute Honey Spot of Lindell
so if this pass across his front or back he's
not going to get full mustard on that shot but
he absolutely unloads and catches GE on the far
side who as balinsky feeds it off and that will do
it for regulation I think this is fantastic so now
we're going to get some fouron four hockey some of
the young guys TP is going to get out there so
we get to see some of the young players in new
situations that's preseason for us all there
we go and here we go R it in with the draw
Sega and he wins it back to his own Zone
Devon deflected never got on that was taken
out by Gerard fired ahead for McKinnon he's got
Ranson in with him Sean trying to get back into
the play set down the slot here's mik with
a shot save by Gibson again and he's been
terrific in the third period in an overtime
and it's Cent ahead Tyler San's going to have
a breakaway he'll race into the Avalanche
Zone down the slot shoots save by goria oh
he looked awful L and he had the shot he
just put it right over the crossbar Here
Comes Jonathan drwan again through Center eyes
crowd loves it drop pass finds the target shot
score Oscar allowed finally beats
Gibson and the ABS have wed 4 to
three in overtime with just 19 seconds
to go and how about the kid coming up big